so maybe I should pull the cat out
excuse me pink cat I could use your
assistance all right oh my god i didn't
get rid of it today oh oh thank god um
all right I'm gonna I think I'm gonna
try put bread in that I feel like I'm
gonna have to use bread on buds at some
point oh my god I love writing but i
think if i put bread in there right then
maybe uh it'll do stuff i I really have
no [ __ ] idea maybe I should hole
punch oh yeah why aren't you visiting
your family today ah the boss is here so
I got it he's not thought about you cal
no one back there I want to see and you
don't want domino here alone getting all
the good leads that do hole punch mind
if I use your hole punch knock yourself
out I got for that
well maybe I can hole punch the cause
he's Wesson's out about a try Oh put
some cards huh Manny I really don't know
just marking come on Kim pods I'm know
what that means why would I mont cards
have no idea all right pick a time all
right maybe I should skipper it out yeah
pink cats not gonna help me in this
situation oh my god why is the brat
there we go holy [ __ ] shove some bread
in this [ __ ] and then give it a try oh
but but what if this like breaks it
again because I've already show up to
things in there please don't sue prick
that looks good something happened if
there's an animation for actually it's
right isn't it let's do back okay dude
seriously the music excellent all right
down we go Marin already let's do oh he
looks at this thing to what's this good
afternoon yes it is we're about to do
this now there's bread in there ah ah
cover again so [ __ ] confusing okay ah
yes so I have to pull out a card I
thought his holes in it now I wonder if
I can let's do that let's give that a
try
Oh Jana man pulls the whole one out did
I just screw this up oh god I hope I
didn't screw this up orissa this yes ah
died of chicken pox time of death yadda
yadda yadda positive attributes
volunteer time reading stores to go oh
that's good is it good like the dying
children in the school amar I think
you're the one for me okay i was gonna
say now what thank God the cutscene well
I would have been horribly confused are
you local [ __ ] yes now it's a cool
company car yes I love his passion hmm
it's a file it's amazing well this is my
favorite
that's quite a tongue you have this herb
it's something weird going on screams a
bit fuzzy times the US you're not the
nurse no you're not here to give me my
medication no but I am here to ease your
pain guess they couldn't save me no no
but there's still a chance you could
save me that she lost a loved waiting
mr. Khan aveda what makes you think I've
been all that good miss Cole Omar meet
you please maji I can see it in your
face and yes the skeletal face is very
very good class ticket to nowhere what
did I do something wrong not according
to your bio it was feeling at least the
part i read was this is a setup or
something like the implication mr.
calavera um yeah anything about your
past you haven't told me quite a bit
considering I've told you nothing what
you mean to animals mean to animals oh
good well I would have to once when I
was volunteering at an animal shelter I
just stop right there my cat balloon
would have been very very offended mmm
yeah let's kill much so much when you
were alive very what is very little mean
never killed anybody I have to confess I
not even a teensy bit maybe I just
wasn't trying hard enough uh-huh I don't
know if I trust you'd cheat on your
husband ever cheated on your husband i'm
mr. calivita there's no ring on my yeah
he is Earl either I guess you'll just
have to trust me then I cheated on your
taxes ever cheated on your dances I've
never paid taxes in my life oh I've
never made enough money to be taxed you
know it's mostly done in tier well she's
perfect this is great let's um
shoplifter were you a big shoplifter
well
cute mmm really but it wasn't my fault
that puppy followed me up best day ever
whooping leaving bestow with you the
best you can do work with me Mitch he's
a dirty dirt well I could do something
bad right now if that would help
wouldn't count sorry thank you what the
Cheetahs hit on him and he's ignored it
she I think that she just offered to
have sex with you and you just said it
wouldn't count are you what are you sure
you're may say this go tomorrow yes
would you like to see my daughter skin
sure where is it it's wherever you guys
put my skin but I have to go straighten
this mess out sorry to be so much
trouble mr. calavera it's no trouble but
please call me Manny wow that's the
first time it's like ended the dialogue
by itself so i have to go straighten
this out what does that mean go talk to
the office lady maybe and wonder if
there's anything else that I can do I'm
sorry I let you down dude let me down
sister or any other buttons that I
haven't yet figured out maybe we can
control help pause directors commentary
you haven't used that yet move toggle
render mode I don't know what that means
examine item use item talk skip dialogue
yeah no I think we've got it all now
early as far as I can tell where Hey yes
hello okay well yeah that did happen
yeah that there's nothing lady that that
happens place you give all the good
glands to do me man
now I'm embarrassed you've embarrassed
the whole office yeah it does sound
really bad when they phrase it like that
it didn't realize what I was doing
walking why does she think she has to
walk oh well was the best package I
could find walking the Domino no pull
Manny woman was a saint and a shoo-in
for a double end ticket that she's not
going to get because you just couldn't
find it and now because of your little
stunt she's out there on her own walking
by herself through the Petrified Forest
facing the demons of the underworld
alone and unprotected ward after a
lifetime of hardship and public service
her destiny stolen by some overreaching
salesman looking for a fat Commission
eating whoa Oh Manny get in there and
stay put until the boys downtown tell us
what they want done with you someone's
gonna take you home in this Calavera and
it ain't gonna be me I'm so sorry Manny
well what are we doing here and coming
up the door but like really when you
think about it he has done a lot of bad
stuff that he probably shouldn't have
done like I didn't think about it too
well until it happened but now I'm
wondering if maybe what has happened to
like with Domino getting all the good
clients like maybe the system's rigged
maybe someone rigged it so that I can't
get any good clients am i actually
supposed to wait here anybody really
have to go oh I know so my new it have
you thought about which one yeah
actually I have
um who's out there I'm you or rather I
was you years ago I don't know I can't
see but looks like he's wearing a beret
do you wearing a beret old me um what
are they gonna do to me what are they
gonna do to me I don't want to alarm you
agent calavera have you ever seen a man
sprouted I don't actually know what that
me good with bugs anymore those parties
anymore then you don't know there's
nothing more horrible than a bite of the
circle that means deadly stinger spreads
a green disease through every calcified
pour on your body leaving your vein with
roots and flocked with us steadily
growing thicker and thicker until you
crash and bloom out in a horror vine
bouquet of pain and frequently suffering
its fragrant oh Jesus this is intense
and your nostril shooting my god stems
and above spear stop leaving you nothing
but a batch of wildflowers on the ground
swarming with but Jesus Christ are you
done boss no I've never seen that um no
uh let's just see if he says something
differently sprouting it's not a bit
there's nothing more horrible than the
light of it he does actually say it
again in a hole scream end up leaving
you know it is a nice story he it's very
well written i must say um I guess get
me out of here get me out of here the
only way out Manuel is to be taken back
in you are truly still loyal to this guy
no no I'm not management my here and
stick you right back in know what that
are
hey stick yeah you have to try harder
than that hmm a man's loyalties decide
but I'm not loyal to this shitty company
that one look I did what I had to do so
what you have to gather than that man
wait a man's loyalty the DoD runs a
crooked game and I in this very true you
would guess that could cause this agency
a lot of trouble yeah I'm gonna blow the
lady alice young man you are an enemy of
the Department of death welcome oh wow
le mones oh wow that could have gone
very differently well this is cool sweet
part of some official club now what this
game's changed so much of the past 10
minutes love cells alliance we're always
looking sweet I knew that was gonna be
used for something I [ __ ] knew it you
need help in our intelligence unit you
know ever of course well I would once a
reaper like yourself mentally but I
uncovered a web of corruption in our
beloved department hmm I have reason to
believe that the Bureau of acquisitions
is cheating very soul that was chartered
to serve I think someone is robbing
these porn he souls of the rightful
destiny price why would that happen
though to march on a treacherous trail
but why unprotected and alone like
babies my way like babies what's your
evidence that's where you come in when
we or should I call you yeah agent
caliper is way cooler no no agent please
I'm not looking to join in a military
organization you don't my job backs what
you want to do cool spy [ __ ] Manny
you're wrong well you won't even be able
to get out of this city without my house
which means of course
you won't be able to find that woman and
you'll never get intense when you're
ready to join it I am ready I was lying
when I said I wasn't I totally want to
be a secret agent I am so down with that
let's go talk to Ava I'll hang on excuse
me while I pull out my pink come fat cat
I can't face serious situations without
it nothing you as you know poof okay hey
but what's it what are you doing here
damn it we're still I could it's my
boss's Secretary's evil twin just me
honey I would have thought it was just
her hey evil twin she's not evil i'm
trying to talk to her you just like
rubbing up on us a secretary I'm a spy
yeah well that's the last time we use
that temp agency mmm doesn't khabar
wonder where you are Don and Domino
we're both locked up in Don's office
with some bigwig from downtown some
fatty and offense hmm who is the fat man
I wonder and how does he fit into this
sinister I don't know why did you ask me
that yeah what does that mean he is just
for me mmm how long have you been a spy
Salvador recruited me about a year ago I
couldn't resist him he's just so totally
what are you working on there I'm trying
to get this radio working so we can use
it in the field but it looks pretty
hopeless Salvador's right we need good
old homing pigeons hey do I finally get
to feed the birds bread agents no it's
just selling me right now but someday
man i'll be a field agent Ava you got to
get me out of town it does sound
horrible you can't leave Manny we need
access to the DoD computer network if
we're ever gonna find that one and we
can't access without a Salesman like you
the computer IDs you when you log on how
does it do that fingerprints I don't
have no teeth Manny haven't you ever
noticed your computer scanning you know
what's going on I thought that was just
a power surge we need your teeth Manny
we can't let you go sorry
so you won't help me out of here sorry
I'll help you out but not your teeth
thinking of well yeah but I mean I want
to do it anyway I'm totally [ __ ] down
this is like the coolest [ __ ] ever and I
also just want to say that I think it's
awesome that sprouting is a thing and
that this universe is so [ __ ] intense
and probably that his head's moving
right now you see that